Es una temporada muy importante para varios futbolistas, para los que quizás sea su última
oportunidad de brillar en la Premier League.
Hoy, en la media inglesa, 10 jugadores que no pueden fallar.
Un momento, un momento, antes de que arranque el vídeo, dejadme contaros que se acerca
un nuevo viaje de la media inglesa.
Al fin de semana, el 18 y 19 de octubre, viajamos a Inglaterra para vivir en directo a un nuevo
partido del Harvard Town como hicimos la temporada pasada.
Solo 289 euros, que incluye todo el fin de semana.
El viernes saldremos desde Londres en autobús hacia Leicester.
Esa noche ya estaremos ahí en Leicester tomando unas cervecillas.
Sábado haremos un tour por Leicester por la mañana, nos iremos a Harvard para ver el
partido y vivir el tercer tiempo con los muchachos.
Y por la noche, los que hayan venido a otros viajes ya saben lo que les espera.
Y domingo regreso a Londres.
¿Qué incluyen esos 289 euros?
Lo que no incluyen son los vuelos, pero sí que incluyen todos los traslados en autobús,
dos noches de hotel, desayuno y por supuesto la entrada al partido.
Con el enlace que tenéis aquí abajo podéis comprar ya vuestro viaje para acompañarnos,
para ir juntos con toda la comunidad de la media inglesa a vivir este partido el sábado
18 de octubre.
Os esperamos.
El año pasado, Pablo, hicimos un vídeo sobre futbolistas que estaban ante su última oportunidad,
que no podían fallar y antes de este vídeo, de hecho, vamos a hacer un repaso.
Porque si hacemos este vídeo ahora es porque el anterior nos gustó y ha dado resultados
interesantes.
Somos el anti-youtube, es la realidad.
La gente haría ahora un reaccionando a los 10 jugadores que no podían fallar y luego
subirían el 10 jugadores que no pueden fallar de este año.
Pero como no nos da tiempo y queremos ya subir este vídeo, porque si no lo vamos a subir
en la jornada decimoquinta, pues tenemos que hacer ahora un mini reaccionando rápido.
Los futbolistas que pusimos el año pasado fueron Sandro Tonali.
No falló.
Fantástico.
Rastford, que se fue en enero cedido al Villa tras ser apartado por Amorim y las lesiones
frenaron su recuperación y ahora está en el Barça.
Yo creo...
Te diré que mitad-mitad.
O sea, si no llega a hacer esos buenos seis meses en el Aston Villa, ahora mismo no estaría
en el Barça y creo que ahora vuelve a tener una oportunidad para hacerlo bien.
Yo creo que no falló, fíjate.
A pesar de todo.
Pero con lo que hizo en el Villa se ganó ese paso al Barça.
Regim Sterling ni siquiera ha tirado a puerto con el Arsenal en 500 minutos y ahora está
apartado por el Chelsea.
Recuerdo que Regim Sterling es del 94, tiene 31 años.
Quiere un año más que yo.
Bueno, no fue nuestra culpa.
No podía fallar, pues ha fallado y está apartado.
Bueno, pero no era un vídeo diciendo estos futbores no van a fallar.
Claro, claro, era un vídeo analizando que es la última oportunidad.
No, pero quiero decir que me llama la atención que hay varios que fallaron y efectivamente
no podían fallar, en el sentido de que se han llevado un gran palo después de fallar
En esa temporada, Regim Sterling estaba apartado por el Chelsea y salió fatal lo suyo en el
Arsenal.
Pero es que el siguiente es Darwin Núñez, que lo pusimos en ese vídeo, fue titular
solo ocho partidos y marcó cinco goles.
Se ha ido a la legilal.
Así que es otro ejemplo de no podías fallar.
Era tu año para establecerte en el Liverpool y no lo hizo.
Otro que creo que no terminó de fallar es Jadon Sancho.
Jugó 31 partidos con el Chelsea, 19 de titular, tres goles, cuatro asistencias y ahora se
ha ido al Aston Villa.
Se parece un poco al caso Rashford, un poco peor, en el sentido de que ha comprado otra
vida.
Ahora creo que ahora sí que va a ser su última oportunidad a Aston Villa, no vamos a repetir
su nombre en este vídeo, pero al menos ha conseguido una temporada más de margen.
Otro que metimos en ese vídeo es Calvin Phillips.
Bueno, jugó 19 partidos con el Eapswich Town, bajaron a segunda división los Tractor Boys
y él se ha quedado en la plantilla del Manchester City, pero como ultimísima opción si hay
una hecatombe y se lesiona por ocho meses Rodrigo Hernández.
Así que no contéis mucho con él.
Aaron Ramsdale encajó 66 goles en 30 partidos con el Southampton, encajó 2,5 goles más
de los que deberías o alguna estadística avanzada, ahora está cedo en el Newcastle
con una opción de compra, pero suplente.
Y para mí yo te diría que Aaron Ramsdale falló, porque no dio ninguna razón para
que un equipo de la Premier League lo fichara para seguir siendo titular.
Mi problema con él es el destino que eligió, que es un destino en el que creo que casi
cualquier portero del mundo no habría destacado.
Ahora bien, se fue al Newcastle, yo pensaba que por la apuesta que hacía el Newcastle
el que iba a jugar era él, pero no estaba a favor de eso, porque creo que Nick Pope
sigue siendo mejor portero que Ramsdale y una certeza para el Newcastle.
Bueno, pues en el momento en que hacemos este vídeo Nick Pope sigue siendo titular indiscutible
en la portería de los MacPies.
Otro de los que metimos fue Emil Smith-Rowe, y Emil Smith-Rowe como siempre con él te
deja a veces con buena sensación, a veces con mala.
Luego 25 partidos de titular, 6 goles, 3 asistencias, empezó bien, luego se desinfló
y ahora mismo su pente Josh King, que tiene 18 años.
Entonces bueno, creo que sí que ha fallado en el concepto de que no es un futbolista
que la tengamos en cuenta cuando pensemos mucho en el fulham.
Kepa, caso extrañísimo, porque Kepa no falló, jugó 31 partidos de titular con el Bournemouth,
con el Bournemouth recibió 39 goles tan solo y además paró dos goles más de los que
debería según la estadística avanzada.
Sí, hizo muy bien, clave para ir a Ola, pero es él el que ha decidido en vez de quedarse
en el Bournemouth y seguir siendo titular en un equipo de esa parte de la tabla irse al
Arsenal al ser suplente a Virraya.
Creo que deportivamente no falló y es él el que ha elegido volver a estar en un equipo
top para ser suplente, pero la oportunidad de jugar en un Bournemouth lo hubiera seguido
teniendo.
Pero sí que creo que fue una buena temporada para él, el Bournemouth lo quería, se lo
quería quedar y ya a partir de su decisión.
Evidentemente no se lo deseo, pero si en Rayas rompe la mano mañana, estás ya directamente
el siguiente en la parrilla para tener minutos de grandísima calidad, como también tiene
un poco la experiencia en el Real Madrid.
No fue bueno el paso de Kepa por el Real Madrid, pero ahí tuvo muchos minutos en una portería
de primerísimo nivel cuando estuvo lesionado Courtois.
Y terminamos con el último de todos, que este me temo que sí ha fallado aunque sigue
en la Premier League, pero no le está viendo mucho mejor en el Leeds.
Dominic Calderluin, el antiguo delantero del Everton, que jugó 19 partidos de titular
y metió tres goles con los Toffees.
Se ha ido ahora con los Whites libre y sigue con la misma deriva en cuanto a sus problemas
con el gol graves.
De hecho ha tenido uno de los peores estrenos con el Leeds United que yo he visto nunca,
fue en Copa de la Liga si no me equivoco y fue un partido en el que falló un penalti
en la tanda, falló dos ocasiones clarísimas, en fin, no andan las cosas muy bien para Calderluin,
otro que no podía fallar y falló.
Esa fue la lista del año pasado, por lo tanto ninguno de estos se va a repetir en la de
año y para que veáis un poco cómo es la dinámica de este vídeo y que lo que decimos
se cumple.
Si eres alguno de los que están en esta lista y estás viendo el vídeo, ponte las pilas
porque no vas a tener otra oportunidad.
Es tu momento de hacer una buena temporada, si no haces una buena temporada, tiene pinta
de que ya es un punto de no retorno.
Y sabes quién me haría mucha ilusión que viera este vídeo porque fue durante muchos
años mi jugador favorito.
Abrimos el vídeo con él.
Mason Mount, hombre, es ahora nunca, jugador del Manchester United de 26 años, en la 20-21
se convirtió en el jugador más joven en marcar un gol en eliminatorias de Champions
League con el Chelsea.
Ganó esa Champions League siendo clave en la semifinal y dando también una asistencia
en la final.
Fue nombrado jugador del año del club, al igual que también lo fue nombrado en la siguiente
temporada, la 21-22, donde marcó 11 goles y dio dos asistencias en Premier League.
La siguiente temporada, la 22-23, aquella temporada de desastrosa con Graz Hanpotter,
en el Chelsea no pudo mantener su nivel y fue titular solo 20 partidos de Premier con
tres goles y dos asistencias.
En verano se marchó al Manchester United por 55 millones de libras y ha sido un completo
desastre porque apenas ha podido jugar por las lesiones.
Con los red de Evils se ha jugado solo 1.125 minutos en dos temporadas en Premier League,
marcando dos goles y todavía no ha dado ni una asistencia en más de dos temporadas en
Premier.
Se ha perdido ya 50 partidos por lesión y esta temporada ha empezado siendo titular
pero se ha vuelto a lesionar, como veis en la imagen.
Cumple 27 años en enero y es año mundial, así que es la última oportunidad también
para no solo recuperar el estatus que tenía de gran estrella de la Premier League, sino
de poder ir al Mundial con Inglaterra, cosa que no hace ir con Inglaterra desde el Mundial
de Qatar 2022.
Al menos que sirva de punto de inflexión un mínimo buen rendimiento en el Manchester
United de cara a volver a construir una carrera como lo que prometía que iba a ser.
Yo sigo pensando que si Mason Mount mañana se retira del fútbol puede decir que los
tres buenos años que tuvo en el Chelsea fueron fantásticos y que eso ya no se los quita
con 26 años estará hablando así de Mount hace mucho que es un futbolista que no vemos
las cualidades que en su día no es que se le intuyeran es que se le vieron.
Yo pensaba que lo que está siendo Palmer en el Chelsea va a ser Mount, así era mi
estimación de Mount.
Otro de los futbolistas en este caso por ahora en el momento que hacemos el vídeo con mejor
perspectiva de cara a lo que puede ser esta temporada porque es el jugador del mes de
agosto es Jack Grilish a quien también hemos metido en este vídeo.
Fíjate que me voy a posar.
Es el culpable de que no hayamos hecho el vídeo de la reacción porque si esperamos
una semana más para publicar este vídeo Grilish ya ha metido 50 goles en premio.
Nunca antes había recibido el premio al jugador del mes así que me alegro mucho por él.
De hecho también os recomiendo ver el vídeo en el que se lo entrega Leberton porque se
ve una reacción de genuina sorpresa e ilusión.
Es con Kiernan Dusbury Hall, están los dos como sentados preparados para hacer un vídeo
con el equipo de redes sociales de Leberton y es Dusbury Hall el que le dice un regalo
por tu cumpleaños.
No se lo espera Jack Grilish y cuando le enseña el trofeo de verdad digo que me alegró mucho
ver la cara de ilusión de Grilish porque, ostras, vi a un tipo que ha vuelto a recuperar,
vuelvo a usar el mismo término pero la ilusión por jugar al fútbol en un equipo en el que
él se identifica.
Subí una foto a Instagram después del segundo o tercer partido con Leberton y parecía
que llevaba jugando, iba a decir en Woodison Park, parecía que llevaba jugando en el Hildy
Dickinson Stadium toda la vida por la relación que tiene con la afición y verdaderamente
para él ha sido volver a reencontrarse con el fútbol.
Ya sabéis que desde la temporada 22-23, la temporada del triplete del Manchester City
ha pegado un gran bajón el rendimiento de Grilish.
Ese año en Premier League marcó 5 goles y dio 7 asistencias y en la Champions League
generó 35 ocasiones de gol, 12 más que cualquier otro jugador y el récord histórico de una
temporada de Champions League para un jugador inglés.
Se dio titular en 6 de 10 partidos contra el Big Six en la Premier League, en la final
de la FA Cup también empezó en el 11 y en todos los partidos de las eliminatorias de
Champions League así que quien quiera negarle la importancia en aquel triplete a Jack Grilish
se está equivocando.
Dicho esto, desde entonces como ya os decíamos su rendimiento cayó en picado e incluso se
quedó sin marcar en todo 2024 como año natural que fue un registro que le persiguió durante
meses.
La temporada pasada solo marcó un gol en competición liguera y en todas las competiciones
apenas jugó 1500 minutos.
Ya había perdido completamente la confianza de Pep Guardiola y es por eso por lo que
se ha ido al Everton de Eibit Mois con una opción de compra de 50 millones de libras.
Yo pagaba los 100 otra vez.
Yo eso es pagaría.
50 millones de libras en este momento ahora está cedido y lleva ya 4 asistencias en 4
partidos por eso ha sido jugador del mes de la Premier League.
Lo estamos viendo otra vez pegado a la banda.
Por ahora nos está moviendo demasiado por esa zona del 10 donde también nos ha gustado
mucho verlo pero tiene pinta de que Mois lo quiere exactamente como lo que dice este
mapa de calor.
Reciben la banda bien abierto y sé el dueño de esa zona de ese costado izquierdo del área
y a partir de ahí genera ocasiones para ti o sobre todo para los demás.
Sé que la muestra es muy pequeña en estos mapas de calor de sofás core me refiero al
temporada 25-26 pero me parece ya importante que ni siquiera se intuye que se vaya a mover
por el centro como se movió el año pasado un poco en el Manchester City.
Tiene 30 años en Acha así que realmente está ante la última oportunidad de ir a
un mundial en este caso evidentemente con Inglaterra.
Selección con la que no va desde hace un año.
El primer jugador y el segundo los hemos tirado también un poco porque es su última oportunidad
no solo para brillar en Premier League sino también para ir al mundial y vamos con el
tercero que yo creo que verá el mundial 100% pero hay que ver cómo va.
Si como la gran estrella del proyecto que era lo que venía siendo los últimos años
o como un suplente de Colpalmer porque hablamos en el tercer caso de Phil Foden desde la temporada
2021 que empezó a ser importante con el Manchester City había ido mejorando temporada tras temporada.
De hecho su mejor nivel fue en la 23-24 donde fue nombrado jugador del año por la Premier
League también por la Asociación de Periodistas que siguen el fútbol en Inglaterra y también
por los propios jugadores marcando 19 goles y dando 8 asistencias además de convirtiéndose
en el jugador más joven en ganar 6 Premier Leagues paréntesis ¿cómo ha ganado ya 6
Premier Leagues?
Bueno.
O sea Phil Foden ha ganado 6, ah las ha ganado todas las de Guardiola.
¿Ha ganado 6 Premier Leagues?
Así es Phil.
No lo tengo.
Tiene 25 años.
Es el único que creo que le puede quitar el récord a Ryan Geeks.
Un récord que me parece imposible son 13 Premiers, Skol son 11.
Joder pero es que el problema de Geeks es que siento que ya va tarde Foden.
A la mínima que te aparezca un Liverpool como ha aparecido o yo que sé pues te aparezca
el Arsenal como candidato es que son 13 tío.
Es que Phil Foden no va ni por la mitad.
Ya ha ganado 6.
O sea es que tiene 13 ligas Ryan Geeks.
De verdad estas cosas son las que siempre insistimos para daros una dimensión de lo
que ha sido el Manchester United y de lo que es el Manchester United como institución.
13 Premier Leagues no he jugado.
La temporada pasada Phil Foden solo marcó 7 goles y dio 2 asistencias en Premier League
y fue titular tan solo dos de las últimas 10 jornadas siendo suplente incluso en la
final de CIC que perdió el equipo Sky Blue contra el Crystal Palace.
Aquí en este gráfico vais a ver el bajón general que ha tenido Phil Foden de la temporada
23-24 a la 24-25.
Menos minutos, muchos menos goles generados, menos tiros, también peor conversión porque
la diferencia entre sus goles y los expected goals era menor, menos pases clave, menos
recuperaciones, menos de todo.
En la izquierda veis al mejor jugador de la Premier League y a la derecha veis a un futbolista
que él mismo reconoció que esa temporada lo pasó mal mentalmente.
Como decíamos de cara al Mundial tiene que mejorar porque ahora mismo es el suplente
de Palmer o de Bellingham o de quien quieras.
No, de Jack Greely ese saca, da igual donde lo pongas.
Creo que va a ir con Inglaterra pero necesita recuperar su mejor versión para volver a ser
la gran estrella de los Freelites.
Vámonos ahora al Chelsea amigos porque en el Chelsea hay un futbolista que en su día
yo pensaba que iba a ser uno de los grandes jugadores que marcaría el futuro del fútbol
europeo en su posición y ahora con 24 años, hombre todavía sigues siendo una edad como
para que tengas tiempo para recuperarte pero si quizás estamos hablando en clave Chelsea
de tu última oportunidad y eres tú Wesley Fofana.
Sí amigos el central de los Blues que con 18 años con apenas se cumplía la mayoría
de edad se hizo con la titularidad en el San Etienne y fue entonces cuando lo fichó
en Leicester City, una etapa en la que a mí me maravilló.
Me pareció un futbolista increíble en su primer año.
¿Te acuerdas cómo lo definías?
Siempre, yo ahí veía los vídeos de la media inglesa, no estaba aún, siempre decías
creo que va a ser la próxima gran cosa.
Era como tu por me decir que iba a ser el próximo Salibá.
Sí, me parecía que con él y con Salibá Francia iba a ser arrolladora en esa posición.
Salibá ha acabado siendo lo que prometía, Fofana se quedó por el camino también por
culpa de las lesiones pero una cosa no quita la otra.
En su primer año ganó la FA Cup con el Leicester al Chelsea de hecho y el premio a jugador
joven del año del club pero en verano tuvo esa grave lesión en un partido de pretemporada
ante el Villarreal y a pesar de jugar solo mil minutos el Chelsea lo fichó todavía
confiando en lo que habíamos visto de él por 70 millonazos de libras en agosto de
2022.
En sus tres temporadas en Stamford Bridge ha jugado 2.827 minutos de 15.210 posibles,
lo que supone que solo ha disputado el 18,5% del tiempo disponible en el Chelsea.
Fichó por los Blues hace 1.114 días y ha pasado 656 lesionados.
Cada cifra es peor que la anterior.
No juega más de 2.000 minutos en una temporada desde la 2021 y al final en total desde su
debut en el fútbol profesional en mayo de 2019 es decir 2.315 días ha estado lesionado
1.500 días, el 43% de los días y lleva seis lesiones de rodilla sin contar la del Perone.
No sé si ya un cuerpo así se puede reconducir para el nivel que te exige el Chelsea, no
lo sé porque esto ya va más allá de lo futbolístico y tiene que ver con lesiones
y salud pero sí siento que es esa última temporada para Wesley Fofana, pero a partir
de aquí el Chelsea de cara a próximos mercados una tarea que tiene que cometer es la del
central y ya ahí no se te va a esperar más.
Fofana será vendido en un año si no vuelve a jugar ni un minuto como ha sido costumbre
las últimas temporadas.
Vamos con un futbolista que jamás pensé que íbamos a poner aquí.
Con este equipo.
Con este equipo después de haber estado en la Serie A.
Hablamos de Douglas Lluís, el que era también uno de mis mediocentros favoritos en la Premier
League de mí y de casi todo el mundo cuando estaba en el Villa porque durante sus cinco
temporadas en Premier nunca bajó de los 2.600 minutos siendo un jugador absolutamente clave
para Alastor Villa y de hecho fue el gran jugador que les llevó a competir de nuevo
por la Champions League aunque luego él no disfrutará de esa clasificación.
En sus dos últimas temporadas se convirtió en uno de los mejores centrocampistas de la
Liga sumando además cifras goleadoras a su repertorio con 13 goles generados entre todas
las competiciones en la 22-23 y 20 en la 23-24 que yo estoy cuando lo he puesto me alucinado.
20 goles generados sé que tiraba penaltis.
Muchos penaltis de hecho.
Bueno hay que meterlos.
En la 23-24 siendo un mediocentro.
Su venta del verano pasado se debió a cuestiones de fair play financiero no es que nos lo inventemos
es algo que ha reconocido el propio Aston Villa y su etapa en la Juventus no ha sido
nada buena.
Solo jugó 516 minutos en Serie A y 305 en Champions.
Su último año en el Villa era un fijo en las convocatorias de Brasil pero desde la Copa
América 2024 no ha vuelto a ir y también tiene una doble última oportunidad para
ganarse la confianza de Carlo Ancelotti y para ver si vuelve a ser ese futbolista que
era uno de los mejores centros de la Premier League.
Cuando se fue a la Juventus nosotros le pedíamos para Manchester United ese era el nivel de
Douglas Luiz y creo que...
Como Ancelotti se monte un núcleo duro en Brasil y no entres.
Ya está fuera.
Ahí es difícil entrar.
Claro, nosotros excusamos lo que pasó en la Juve porque no le pudimos ver tanto.
Y que Thiago Motta es un terrorista.
Principalmente por eso.
Con cero partidos vistos de la Serie A.
Thiago Motta terrorista, por algo te echaron.
Pero si tampoco le funciona ahora su carrera no la ha conseguido relanzar en el Forest ya
ese Douglas Luiz que parecía que iba a llegar a un Big Six tendrá que decir adiós y ser
otro tipo de futbolista.
Si hay algún aficionado de la Juve que nos está viendo que nos enfade, no hemos visto
a Douglas Luiz en la Juve, si me dices que no daba una pata o un bote te creo, te creo.
Pero que sepas que nosotros somos Douglas Luizistas y por tanto Thiago Motta terrorista.
Otro futbolista también está ante una de sus últimas oportunidades a pesar de que
tiene 23 años pero aquí sí que quizá hablamos de seguir teniendo oportunidades en primera
línea en la Premier League es Fabio Carballo, el futbolista del Brentford que tras impresionar
en Championship con el Fulham con diez goles y ocho asistencias con apenas 19 años lo
fichó en Liverpool en 2022.
No esos fichajes que ya se intuía que los reds habían hecho con buen ojo, con buen
timing y que podía marcar el futuro del equipo por entonces de Jurgen Klopp.
Esta temporada, perdón esa temporada jugó 640 minutos y estuvo además en la prelista
del Mundial con Portugal.
En la 23-24 estuvo media temporada de seguido en el LRB Leipzig y la otra mitad en el Hull
City donde generó 11 goles en 20 partidos.
Su primera temporada en el Brentford no ha sido nada fácil porque solo jugó 445 minutos
de Premier League y aunque sigue siendo muy joven, es cierto, ya os decimos tiene 23 años
recién cumplidos en un año en el que se han ido VISA, BVM, se necesita otra vez líderes
más allá incluso en la marcha de Norgar, también se ha ido Tomás Frank como posible
valedor de Fabio Carballo, es ahora donde en este Brentford hay que decirlo francamente
de reconstrucción por mucho que su objetivo sea seguir estando en la Premier League, tienes
que hacer ese paso adelante.
Creo que la plataforma es buena para él, tener hueco y brillar con VISA y con Embemora
es muy difícil tener minutos en las zonas donde le gusta moverse a Fabio Carballo, incluso
te añado si quieres Damsgar, toda esa zona es muy difícil para Carballo, pero esta temporada
es ya la de verdad porque si no a los equipos de la Premier no les va a valer con un jugador
que lo mejor que hemos visto no deja de ser en segunda división pero no en primera.
Ahora dos goles muy importantes, esto hay que reconocérselo, el que abrió el marcador
ante el Bournemouth en Copa y el empate ante el Chelsea, así que el inicio por ahora es
positivo.
Sobre todo sería la última oportunidad para que consideremos a Fabio Carballo como un
futbolista útil para Brentford, si este año no lo hace bien, igual le habría que pensar
hasta un paso por Champions y que fue donde lo hizo bien en el Halftime.
Vamos ahora con un futbolista que hemos estado a punto de no meter, pero claro tiene un 28
años, todo puede que se une este a tiempo para volver al nivel que tenía antes de que
la EFE comenzara una investigación contra él porque hablamos evidentemente de Lucas
Paquetá, el mismo reconoció en un comunicado tras ser absuelto de las acusaciones de amaño
de partido que podrían haber acabado con su carrera que por fin podía volver a jugar
al futbol con una sonrisa en la cara.
Es un futbolista que evidentemente ha estado atormentado estos dos años por la investigación
que estaba haciendo la Federación Inglesa.
La investigación comenzó en agosto de 2023 y le ha afectado mucho en su juego, a finales
de la temporada pasada se puso incluso a llorar tras ver una amarilla en una imagen que fue
muy dura de ver y su mujer reconoció en un comunicado que su familia llevaba viviendo
una pesadilla los dos últimos años.
La pasada temporada fue sin duda la peor que tuvo en la Premier League con 4 goles y 0
asistencias, viniendo además de 4 goles y 6 asistencias que eran unos buenos números.
Hay que recordar que en verano de 2023 estuvo a punto de fichar por el City a cambio de
85 millones de libras y este es el punto.
Claro, tan a punto que si no llega a iniciar la EFE una investigación que luego, pues
de la cual Paquetá ha sido absuelto, ahora mismo Paquetá sería futbolista en el Manchester
City, era ese nivel de jugador pero es que nunca hemos vuelto a recuperar esas cotas
de nivel.
Aún tiene 28 años, esta temporada lleva ya dos goles, uno de esos con la celebración
tan mítica que hemos visto en el inicio de coger el teléfono y descolgarlo y en su última
oportunidad sin duda para intentar volver, no sé si a un Big Six, pero a tener el nivel
de jugador del Big Six porque creo que si tienes una temporada, lo ya a Rod Bowen, por
lo mucho que te dediques en el West Ham, volveremos a ver un Paquetá absolutamente
brillante pero es que los dos últimos años hemos visto un futbolista que se parece muy
poco al que nos encantó en su primer año en Londres y es normal, es que hasta él mismo
y su mujer han reconocido que estaba viviendo un auténtico encierro.
Yo te diría que en este sentido el concepto de última oportunidad tiene algo mejor que
ver con tu última oportunidad para ser un jugador en estos próximos años de nivel Champions,
no para que te ficha el City pero sí para que te fiche un equipo que sea en Inglaterra,
sea en otro lado, tenga presencia constante en la máxima competición continental porque
tal y como están ahora con las cosas en el West Ham, hombre no puedo ser muy positivo
para el futuro inmediato que es el que necesita Paquetá, con 28 años ya no puedes estar pensando
en bueno venga creo en el proyecto, hombre sí pero hasta cierto punto, así que de ahí
un poco que lo incluimos en este vídeo.
Lo mismo pasa a su manera con Edin Ketia, con el delantero del Crystal Palace, 26 años
tiene el canterano del Arsenal que fichó por los Eagles por 30 millones el verano pasado,
se convirtió así en el segundo fichaje más caro de la historia del equipo del San Jose
Park en toda su carrera en ese momento por supuesto.
Venía de marcar 14 goles en Premier League en las últimas tres temporadas en el Arsenal,
todo ello habiendo sumado 3.000 minutos.
Lo cual estaba bastante bien.
Hombre no estaba mal, yo sobre todo que en Ketia cada vez que saltaba al campo me parecía
que se le quedaba demasiado grande el Arsenal pero hombre yo daba por hecho que si daba
un paso atrás le iba a ir muy bien y a mí el fichaje en Ketia por el Palace me gustó
bastante.
Luego ha sido un desastre absoluto porque el año pasado, la temporada pasada marcó
sólo tres goles en 1.034 minutos, dos de ellos además contra los Wolverhampton Wanderers
en la penúltima jornada, sin jugarte demasiado y contra un equipo que tampoco se estaba
ya jugando nada.
Fue el cuarto jugador con peor diferencia ante sus goles y sus goles esperados con menos
2.8, es decir según la estadística avanzada midiendo la calidad de sus ocasiones tendría
que haber marcado casi tres goles más de los que marcó.
Esta temporada la ha empezado lesionado y parece que no volverá hasta finales de septiembre
y a sus 26 años, hombre con el fichaje de Cristán Tosuche pues empieza a parecer que
si el fichaje no funciona tampoco este año ya le buscarán una salida.
Y aquí el tema es, saliste de Lars en el concierto caché pero ya salir del Palace
con este caché renovado te ponen graves problemas tu situación en Premier.
A mí me parece que si este año no funciona ya será un equipo que te lee por no descender.
Te irá a salvar Lee de turno por decir un ejemplo.
Vamos ahora con un futbolista que tiene una carrera muy extraña porque sobre todo sigue
siendo muy joven, bueno muy joven de que aún no está.
¿Qué?
¿Sí?
Bueno, bueno, sí, es muy edad de hecho, muy edad.
¡Hombre!
¡28 años!
Así que oye 28 años que tiene Zinchenko que está hecho un chaval.
A lo que voy es que ya hemos viéndole tanto tiempo que uno podría pensar que Zinchenko
tiene ya 30 y pico años.
Hay un poco de humor en esta imagen, no sé exactamente qué es de su cara pero no le
veo del todo contento en esta situación.
Hombre lo que parece es que le está entrevistando Belcebu.
Claro, claro.
Con la cara de susto, Alexander.
Carrera extraña, tras llegar al Manchester City en 2016 y acabar jugando más de 1000
minutos en Liga con los Citizens cuatro temporadas seguidas, más o menos era un futbolista importante,
se fue al Arsenal por 35 millones de euros en 2022.
Fue clave para elevar el listón competitivo del club y él mismo contó que cuando él
llegó al Arsenal sus compañeros se rieron de él porque les dijo que había que olvidarse
de luchas por el top 4 y que había que centrarse en la pelea por el título.
Bueno, el Arsenal lideró gran parte esa Premier League con Zinchenko jugando más de 2000 minutos
y al final él luego recordaba que ya nadie se reía de él por decir que había que luchar
por la Premier League.
La siguiente temporada jugó 1700 minutos, pero la anterior se quedó tan solo en 500
minutos, además sin sufrir ningún tipo de lesión grave.
Se ha quedado fuera de la lista del Europa League en su paso ahora al Nottingham Forest
porque se ha ido directamente al Nottingham Forest cedido.
Le queda un año en contrato con el Arsenal, así que veremos qué pasa la temporada que
viene pero a pesar de que se ha quedado fuera de la lista del Europa League, como se ha
lesionado Olaaina, parece, según la información que tenemos ahora mismo que nos llega desde
Inglaterra, parece que le van a inscribir porque la UEFA te permite hacer esos cambios
cuando se trata de una lesión de gravedad como la de Olaaina.
Tiene 28 años y con Postecohlu creo que puede encontrar una plataforma para volver a ser
importante en la Premier League, en el Arsenal.
Él fue importante para elevar el listón, paradójicamente luego él no ha podido mantenerse
en ese listón que él mismo fijó en el Arsenal.
Zimacar, Azzioli, Luis Schielli, es imposible, pero ahora con Postecohlu que le gustan mucho
a la gente que se mete por dentro, un equipo que va a tener aspiraciones europeas como
el Forrest, es una oportunidad para volver a ser importante porque la última temporada
ya en el Arsenal apenas ha jugado.
Y terminamos con otro de los que desde luego llevan este vídeo tatuado en la frente porque
antes justo de grabar teníamos duda entre varios, teníamos que elegir solo a uno de
una lista para cerrar estos 10 y hemos elegido Armando Brocha, al delantero del Burnley,
que tiene 24 años, parece mentira, y por el que han pagado 23 millones, a pesar de
que su último gol en Premier League data del 2 de octubre de 2023, hemos hecho arqueología
para encontrar el último.
Desde aquel buen año fue contra el Fulham y un partido en tres semanas, lo recuerdo
perfectamente.
Desde aquel buen año en el Southampton con 6 goles, que tampoco es que sea muchísimo,
en la 21-22 solo ha metido 2 goles en Premier League entre Chelsea, Fulham y Everton, 3 clubes,
2 goles.
Ha perdido infinidad de lesiones, eso desde luego que hay que decirlo lo primero de todo,
especialmente el cruzado que se lo rompió a finales de 2022 y un problema en el Aquiles
al inicio de la temporada 24-25.
La reflexión con Brocha es que es su última oportunidad esta temporada para, creo, ser
considerado un delantero que puede jugar en la Premier League.
Si esta temporada en el Burnley no sale bien, o bien te vas con el Burnley a segunda y jugas
o las ofertas que te van a llegar creo que ya van a empezar a ser principalmente de Champions
League y las de Premier van a tener más que ver con poco protagonismo y no muy altas
expectativas.
Entonces es tu último año para agarrarte a la Premier.
Lo que es increíble es que hace un año y nueve meses la red social X, otro la conocía
como Twitter, recibió el que quizás es uno de sus mejores tweets, además por parte de
un periodista con buenísima información como Matt Lowe.
Pero es que en enero de 2024, pon la imagen Jesús, el Chelsea según Matt Lowe valoraba
Armando Brolla en unos 50 millones de libras y lo mejor del tweet dice bueno puede que
no sea tan loco porque el Brighton valora en 100 millones de libras a Iván Ferguson.
Es que este tweet es el que peor ha envejecido la historia.
Un millón de personas que han visto este tweet y se han sacado los ojos.
Claro, pero yo entiendo al Chelsea, coño, si Iván Ferguson vale 100 millones de libras,
Armando Brolla vale 50.
Bueno, Ferguson está en la Roma, que no sé cómo le está yendo, pero lleva dos temporadas
malas y yo pensaba que ya este año iba a estar en el United.
Es que ha apuntado muy alto.
Y luego Armando Brolla no ha valido 50 millones de libras, ha valido unas 17-18 y está en
el Barley.
¿Y te ha parecido un buen traspaso?
Bueno, no, me ha perdido el mejor traspaso del Chelsea en años.
Y no creo que la verdad que le vaya a ir bien.
Mira, vamos a hacer una cosa para hacernos un favor al año que viene.
¿Cuáles crees que van a aprovechar la oportunidad?
Mason Mount, sí o no?
No.
No le veo demasiado güey con él.
Jack Greelis, sí.
Hombre, a este y el C ahora a favor de la corriente, pero sí.
Phil Fauden.
Venga, sí, creo que va a tener un buen año.
Yo sí.
No un año extraordinario, pero un buen año.
Wesley Fofana, no.
Douglas Luiz, me jode, pero creo que no.
Creo que no.
¿Y qué pasa?
Que justo venimos de que el Nottingham Forest haya sido eliminado en la Copa de la Liga
con Douglas Luiz de titular, con una remontada, después de ir dos goles por encima, contra
el Swansea.
Claro.
Fabio Carballo.
No.
Pero, y no voy a entender qué pasó.
Bueno, tiene que volver a encontrarse con Henry.
Fabio Carballo.
No.
Venga, te voy a llevar a contraria.
Yo creo que no.
Venga.
No porque tenga algo de gracia.
Sí, Lucas Paqueta.
No.
La temporada del West Ham va a ser horrible.
Es que no la acompaña el equipo.
No la acompaña el equipo.
Pero venga, no, no, no.
Edi Nketia, rotundamente no.
Sí, porque va a salir cedido.
En enero, algún equipo iba a hacer una segunda mitad de temporada muy buena.
Edi Nketia, en enero cedido, al Sunderland y se va a marcar cinco goles en la segunda
mitad de temporada.
Zinchenko, sí.
O sea, Postekoglu es perfecto para él.
Ha tenido una suerte increíble.
No.
Armando Broya, ni de coña.
Tampoco.
Armando Broya, para mí ya ha perdido la oportunidad.
O sea, está aquí de rebote.
Dinos tú en comentarios qué piensas de todos estos jugadores con el formato Sí, No.
Y cada uno para que veamos qué opinas sobre si van a aprovechar su última oportunidad.
Y otros jugadores que crees que también están en este mismo problema.
Nos vemos en el próximo vídeo.
Y luego este dentro de un año para revisar qué ha pasado con todos ellos.
Suerte para esta temporada a los 10 señalados.